[Music]
for the past half century the united
states of america has dominated a
category no one would ever want to own
we have as a nation one of the most
radical abortion regimes in the world
it might surprise you to know this you
certainly won't hear it from anyone on
any other network but that supposedly
extreme mississippi law headed for the
supreme court which would block most
abortions after 15 weeks would be right
at home in europe when all those nations
the left wants to emulate in other areas
of policy like france and sweden ban
abortion in fact all the countries you
see on your screen ban elective abortion
at 12 weeks
none of them have what america
effectively has in many states abortion
up to the point of birth for that you
have to look at our moral equals in
nations like china or north korea
why is it that america has persisted in
this extreme regime even as the rest of
the world woke up to the moral reality
of what abortion does to families and
societies it's a complicated story but
it's also very simple really many of us
have been willing to look the other way
and a vast industry of powerful forces
in our country have worked very hard to
make sure that we do
understand there is no more important
single issue today to the left than the
issue of abortion it is an item of faith
they are wedded to stronger than any
religious conviction if you've ever been
taken aback by the vitriol violence and
false accusations leveled against any
who challenge abortion you'll know what
i'm talking about the kind that makes a
young woman spit on an elderly priest
it's safer to attempt sacrilege in a
cathedral than abortion rallies
to criticize the abortion regime is to
place yourself at odds not just with the
most powerful activist groups and donors
it is to take on the woke corporatists
and hollywood and our corrupt media and
big tech and
well just about everybody with power in
america today
since the moment roe versus wade
short-circuited the legal conversation
about abortion the pro-abortion left has
worked to gaslight the country into
believing things that just aren't true
he pretended they wanted abortions to be
rare they claimed they didn't profit
from them they denied they sold organs
they refused to acknowledge the science
of what we know about the development of
unborn babies utterly unknown to the
authors of roe by the way and they
ignored the terrible and tragic impact
on america's poorest and most vulnerable
families and on the black community in
particular more black babies are aborted
than born in new york city every year
and that's fine with them
they also did everything they could to
build up men like bill clinton and
andrew cuomo because the abortion agenda
is always more important
why do you think joe biden flipped on
the height amendment and taxpayer-funded
abortions after an entire career of
saying he believed the opposite every
sunday his head bowed in his church he
knows who runs the left he wanted to be
president and he was willing to make a
deal to do it
and in every aspect of this effort the
pro-abortion left has had the strong
advocacy of a media that has displayed
more corruption on this topic than
perhaps any other if you watch abc nbc
or cbs today pro-life women simply do
not exist
the media's coverage of this issue is
indistinguishable from planned
parenthood press releases and the
journalists who cover it are universally
not just pro-choice but obviously
pro-abortion
but now
at long last something is happening the
energy in the pro-life movement is like
nothing we've seen before
abortion is no longer accepted as an
unobjectionable good the shout your
abortion movement where women are
encouraged by the abortion lobby to
boast about killing their children comes
across as desperate and sad
decades of ultrasound pictures on
refrigerators and women brave enough to
talk about miscarriage and loss have a
way of changing minds when iceland says
they've eradicated down syndrome good
people cringe because we know what that
really means
i am a man
see me as a human being
not a birth defect
syndrome
i don't need to be
eradicated
i don't need
to be
cured
and when naive leftists regularly
suggest that pro-lifers like children so
much maybe we should force the dads to
pay child support for unborn babies our
response is your terms are acceptable
there is today renewed hope among those
who believe every unborn baby has a
right to life that the supreme court may
at last reopen this significant question
for us to decide as citizens and states
instead of leaving the deepest moral
question of life and death to nine
people in robes
tonight i'm going to be talking to a
number of heroic pro-life women who
brought us to this moment their
determined work in law and politics and
culture is absolutely the reason we are
at this point so many of us despaired
and once thought impossible they've
taken on the goliath of the abortion
industry and all its vile works with
fearless dedication to be a voice for
the voiceless
much of the discussion around abortion
is about the law
and of course we'll talk about that
tonight but there's another law i want
you to consider as you listen and that
is the law written on your hearts
back in 1933 long before roe whitaker
chambers was working as a soviet agent
when his wife found out she was pregnant
despite the initial joy they both knew
that as communist agents such things
were not possible his wife went to see a
doctor to make arrangements when she
came back she was quiet and
non-committal it slowly dawned on
chambers she wanted to keep the child
he asked her as he writes in his
autobiography witness
my wife came over to me took my hands
and burst into tears
dear heart she said in a pleading voice
we couldn't do that awful thing
to a little baby
not to a little baby dear heart
a wild joy swept me
reason the agony of my family the
communist party and its theories the
wars and revolutions of the 20th century
crumbled at the touch of the child
what we are discussing tonight
is the most fundamental question for us
whether the unborn lives that take root
here in america are unique persons with
the right to draw breath and blossom or
whether they are non-persons lives
unworthy of life human weeds as planned
parenthood founder margaret sanger
called them whose destruction is a
public good
the mission that tells us that to
destroy a life is destroy is to destroy
a whole world
the worlds that would have been with
that life in it
look to the law written on your heart
you know this to be true
i'm ben dominic and this is the american
crisis
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else